so ely
who goes by the pronouns they them as a
lead data scientist at tempest labs in
chicago where they build tooling to
deliver oncology data to clients
they've previously worked on distributed
modeling ad spend optimization and
large-scale survey data analysis
they hold a phd in ecology and evolution
from the university of chicago
and ely is going to talk about how to
think like git
so my name is eli sander i am the lead
data scientist at tempest labs
and just to give like a quick one
sentence pitch tempest is hiring for
lots of different positions so if you're
interested in solving difficult problems
in precision medicine with data and ai
come check us out
and today i'm going to talk about how to
think like git
if my slides will advance okay
uh so i wanted to just motivate this by
talking about some times that git has
made my day really difficult
um i have definitely not always been uh
very good at it so there was one time um
my
first internship um out of grad school i
spent
hours working on
a rebase that i ended up pulling in a
co-worker and like he had to spend
forever helping me out
and i felt really bad about
how much of his time i took up he was
very nice to me
um
even worse is the time that i was in
grad school and i pushed so much
simulated data to bitbucket which is a
lot like github if you haven't used it
um they locked my account wouldn't let
me push anything else and i thought i
wouldn't be able to like access my
dissertation anymore
um and then there's just all of the
times that i had some kind of merge
conflict and just panicked and like
deleted the whole repo and started over
um so if any of these uh situation
sounds familiar to you you're not alone
um
it can feel really like a black box and
um pretty scary sometimes but it doesn't
have to be this way and what i want to
do is
help you understand get a little bit
better so that you can have a mental
model for what might be happening um so
that you can debug it like you would
debug your python code or
any other code that you're writing
so
magic school bus style we're gonna go
inside gets brain
and try to understand how it thinks
um so my agenda is first we're going to
design our own version control system
from scratch
uh then we're going to learn how git
works and then we're going to use that
understanding to solve all of our get
problems should be pretty easy right uh
we've got plenty of time for that
so first um
starting from scratch let's build a
version control system and before i do
this i just want to take a second and
talk about why this section is in my
talk
so we could start by um just talking
about how git does things but
um i i think actually spending some time
starting from like not having any
version control system what are the
problems we need to solve and how might
we solve them really gives a lot of
insight into
why git is doing what it's doing um i
actually did this exercise for
a few hours in a big pair programming
project
and uh i didn't get very far it was
really frustrating and i felt like i did
a really bad job at it but i'm so glad i
did it because i learned a ton about
version control and
why it works and what it's doing
so let's start with a really basic
problem if we have no version control
system
uh and we want to make a change to our
code what do you do
so probably you've done something like
um you know you make a change to your
code and then you rename it like
um script three final final um that
happens because you don't have a good
way to checkpoint your code so if you
need to like create these little like
save points or checkpoints in your code
it makes it a lot easier to
have that security that you can go back
and
revert something if it's causing
problems for you
so
we're looking at it from the perspective
of building our own version control
system right so
let's do just like the most basic thing
we can and save a whole new copy of the
code every time so you have some repo
which is a folder which may have other
folders in it files that have code other
things
we're just going to take that whole
folder
and save it somewhere else on the
computer
and let's say we're going to stash it in
like a version control folder that the
user doesn't see the user doesn't need
to know how we're storing it or where um
this is just for us to be able to like
access it when the user wants to get
their code back and then we need to name
these checkpoints somehow
just for simplicity let's just like have
an incrementing number so then it's kind
of like a built-in time record because
commit one comes after commit or comes
before commit two and so on
so here's an example of what our little
like version control system looks like
right now
so we've got this vc folder to short for
version control and let's say all of our
repository history is going in there
then when the user makes a commit and
i'm going to use this kind of this get
language throughout just because i'm
assuming that's familiar to everyone
watching this talk
um so if you run vc commit
let's say that's our little command line
um
command that we run then we
create this checkpoint folder one and we
save uh everything in the repository in
this case test.pi
then we make some changes we add another
file checkpoint it again and then we get
folder two and we have what i'm calling
test pi prime uh an updated version of
that file and then another um file in
there so that's just an example of how
we'll store it
so this seems really inefficient right
um if your repository is big it's going
to take up a ton of space so
let's just solve that for now by zipping
the entire folder and just compress the
whole folder and move on
that's good enough for now
so problem two uh we want to experiment
so
um
let's say you know i'm working from
my checkpoint too and there's a couple
different things i'm working on at once
i want to build this new feature but
it's big it takes a lot of time to build
but then i also have this bug that i
need to fix and i don't want to get the
code mixed up between those two things
i'm calling these different kinds of
changes experiments because maybe we
want to keep them and maybe we want to
get rid of them
um but then we need some concept of
branches and get language
so this suggests a kind of tree
structure right that we need to be able
to split we don't just have this linear
history anymore
so my suggestion is we store this tree
structure in its own file
so now in my like vc folder i
let's say we like added more uh commits
to the history right we have
uh six different commits and um they're
uh meant to replicate this tree
structure that i'm showing on the right
here so we have these two different like
branches or experiments
um
one has uh commits three and five and
one has four and six and again those
numbers are just based on like at what
time did we make that commit
and then we want to store the structure
of this tree itself in this little
tree.txt
uh file
and
maybe a way that we can store that is
um we just append
um
the like parent commit and the um the
most recent commit um to that
uh file every time we make a commit so
i'm using like airflow-ish um
syntax here with the bit shift operator
but i'm just saying commit one points to
two two points to three and so on
so this is okay but it's sort of hard to
keep track of
what an entire branch is
um you have to know what the most recent
commit on that branch is to like move
back and forth between them so we can
keep things more organized by letting
the user name their branches
maybe the user chooses to name them main
and dev and then we can just append the
most recent commit onto that like branch
history
so in this case we just have the whole
history from maine and then that dev
branch we
um show where it splits off it splits
off at two
and any uh commits that we add onto that
and then the final problem i'm gonna
solve in in this little mini version
control system is being able to combine
code from different branches
so let's say we've been working on our
uh big feature for a while and we want
to bring it in from dev to main
so this is like a merge right
um let's say in our system emerge is
just another commit we don't actually
differentiate it at all
um but the only difference is we have
the history of all of the changes from
that branch so we need some way to
identify and resolve any conflicts that
happen between those two
uh code sets
so what i'm going to suggest is that we
compare files using the sha1 hash
and
what a hash function is if you're not
familiar is it's a function that takes
in
the variable length like a file or you
know some code whatever and it produces
a fixed length uh character string and
if it takes in exactly the same text
it'll produce the same hash
so we know for sure
if
we get the same hash of for two
different files those files are the same
and this is really helpful because it
means we can just
um you know accept any files where the
hashes match and then we can just flag
to the user any files that have
different hashes
so we'll just tell the user hey here's
the files that have some mismatch you
need to resolve the conflicts between
them
and just one thing i want to highlight
here is that this idea of a merge is
directional so when you're merging a
into b
um you're adding a commit onto branch b
right so that's a different commit
history than if you're adding uh b into
a
and just to show what that looks like in
our little tree structure so let's say
we want to pull
everything from that dev branch into
main
um
in that case we're just adding a commit
uh commit number seven onto maine this
is what it looks like in our history the
user maybe has to go through the effort
of figuring out how to resolve some
conflicts but
as far as what we're storing in our
system it's just another
commit great so now we have built a
really you know simple basic um
version control system let's see how git
does it
so um a confession for anyone who read
my abstract i mentioned something about
hand-drawn animation i actually um when
i wrote my proposal
um was under the impression that git
stores the changes between
uh commits in each like commit that it
makes and so i had this whole like um
analogy planned of like these animation
cells that you layer on top of each
other i thought it was really clever uh
but when i actually did the research for
the talk i realized this is the way that
a lot of version control systems work
but it's not how git works and git is
actually a lot simpler than this
um so
uh sorry if i misled you into into
coming to this talk but um you know i
learned a lot about git writing it so
that's very exciting for me
um so it actually turns out that git
does what we did which is kind of wild
to me it stores every file every time
you commit like the whole
repo essentially
so that means that every committed
version of every file is stored in the
dot get folder and the dot get folder is
just the equivalent of our vc folder it
stores the repository history for rega
so every file in its entirety is stored
there uh which seems wildly inefficient
at first glance but
you know it works really well actually
the the simplicity of it it's pretty
powerful
um so
let's talk about how git does
checkpointing so um obviously these are
uh commits
so um what git does when you run git
commit is it compresses
and using zlib which is an open source
compression library
and hashes using the sha-1 hash
every file in the repository
and then um the folder structure of your
repository is encoded in a bunch of tree
objects and a tree is essentially a
manifest so it lists out all of the
files and folders
um that are in the repo
and uh basically as like uh pointers to
the hashes
and those tree objects are just in files
it compresses them and it hashes them
and then it makes a commit object and
that's a file that lists the hash of the
tree and the hash of the parent commit
and then along with some user info and a
commit message
and then that's just a file right so it
compresses that and hashes that and
those all go
in the same place
so everything lives in this dot get
folder and then there's a subfolder
called objects so files commits trees
all of that compressed hash
lives in that folder all together
and every object this is actually really
clever really simple and clever is named
after its hash so that means that no
objects are duplicated because when you
make a commit if you haven't changed a
file it's going to have the same hash
so that means that file
uh that file name already exists it'll
just like overwrite it
and just a side note sometimes people
worry about like what if you hash two
different files and you get the same
hash this is called a hash collision
these are basically impossible um this
is so unlikely to happen and it's just
like not worth worrying about at all
um so let's actually look at some of
these objects so what's in a commit so
you can see this first line here uh this
tree object um there's a bunch of random
like characters and numbers uh this is
the hash for that tree object and then
that hash next to the word parent is
um the hash of the parent so these are
also the file names right so now we know
where to find them
then it says that i'm the author and the
committer and my commit message it's a
test for the pi data talk
and now let's this is actually the tree
object if we look at that
if we go to that file that tree hash
so right now we're looking at my website
actually so my website's a github pages
website so it's all like inner repo
um
so this tree object you can see there's
a bunch of
hashes here and there's things that say
like blob and tree
so blobs are essentially files
so
this blob with the hash at the top is my
dot get ignore
if you
find that
hash and uncompress the file you can see
what's in my data bar
um and then those trees are basically
like
hashes for another tree object and
that's like a folder so it'll list if
you go into that tree object everything
that's in my underscore data folder for
example
um yeah so that that's what's in um
commits and trees so let's talk about
how we branch like how we run
experiments
so
branch information is stored in
dot get slash ref slash heads
so here i've listed out everything
that's in that folder you can see
there's two files
um
so i have a master branch and a test dev
branch and if you just print out what's
in one of those files
it is just a hash
and that hash um is a commit object and
it's the commit or the most recent
commit on that branch
and this is basically it the entire tree
structure isn't stored anywhere in a
file the way that we did basically you
can go
back in the get history by looking at
the parent commit in this commit object
and the parent of that commit and so
like working backwards that way you can
get the entire tree history
so
like we did it lets users create name
branches and they just track the head of
each branch
and one thing i want to point out is
that there is no canonical branch uh the
naming conventions of like master or
main or just naming conventions
um so all branches are the same as far
as git is concerned
so finally how do we do merges
this is actually quite similar to what
we did in our little simple example
so
it's got these tree objects right that
gives a listing of all the files so we
can compare everything in the two trees
and then any new files that are in one
tree or the other we can just accept
those changes in from either branch um
so there's no conflicts there we just
bring those all in and then if the files
have the same name check the hash
and if the hash is matched then like we
did we know
the files are the same so we don't have
any conflict
if the hashes are different
then that means there's been some change
on at least one of the branches so we
need to go into the file to understand
what's going on
and then we follow basically the same
process just at the file level rather
than at the tree level
so we compare everything in the two
files find the most recent common
ancestor of the file and we can do this
by going back in the get history and
looking at the hash of this file at each
time point until you find like matching
hashes essentially
so once we know what that common
ancestor is we can accept any unique
changes from either file so if a line is
changed on branch a but not on branch b
then we accept that change in or if
there's a new line rather
so otherwise if there's then changes on
both
uh then git doesn't know what to do it
has to raise a merge conflict and
basically what that's saying is
there's something going on here that a
user needs to look at and just confirm
what's the actual correct thing to do
um so now we have some basic
understanding of how git does things so
let's talk about how this works in
practice and how we can use it to
understand
how our
workflows work in
in practice
so i've made this goofy grew meme uh
basically what i want to point out here
is get doesn't care about what you have
in your local copy or what i call the
working copy it only cares about what's
in the dot kit folder
um
so the dot get folder
that's all git knows about local changes
that you make don't affect your get
history so you can make changes to all
kinds of files if they're not committed
they don't exist as far as git is
concerned which is great you can make
lots of uh changes and experiment and
try things out
um and it doesn't get stored in your
history uh but this can have some
surprising consequences for people who
aren't used to this paradigm
so again the copy that you're looking at
when you have it in front of you on the
computer that's your working copy
get doesn't know about anything that you
haven't staged or committed
and what that means is if you are on one
branch and then you check out a
different commit or a different branch
it doesn't touch those local changes
so if you are starting to work on a bug
fix but you don't commit those work in
progress changes and then you switch
back to main
those changes will follow you and you'll
have that like partial bug fix in your
working copy which can be a little
surprising to people sometimes
yeah so uncommitted changes follow you
from branch to branch
and if you check out a commit that
conflicts with your working copy
git doesn't know what to do because it
doesn't have the hashes it doesn't have
the tree objects it doesn't try to
resolve it it just says no this this is
on you
you have to like either get rid of these
changes or commit them or do something
because i don't know how to fix this
problem
so the take homes here
before you commit or check out
your code always run a git status
because
if you have forgotten that you like made
some changes
um you might get unexpected results so
it's always good to run a git status
just to make sure everything is as
expected
and then also if you have some work in
progress changes and you want to switch
branches it's a really good idea to
commit them even if they're not done uh
you can mark them as work in progress or
whatever you want but it's really useful
to commit them
so that they don't follow you to the
next branch
so next i want to talk about fetching
and remotes
um so uh
you may have seen this meme before
there's no cloud it's just someone
else's computer so remotes work like
this too and remotes are if this term
isn't familiar this is basically
any other uh copy of the git repository
that's on anyone else's computer so
github is a remote or you're like
a co-worker's computer that has a copy
of the repo that's also a remote there
is no remote it's just someone else's
git folder
so
this kind of blew my mind when i
realized this running git fetch is
actually like exactly the same as if
your co-worker emails you their dot git
folder and you copy it into yours
um that's all it's doing it's just
getting the dot get folder and just
plopping it in yours
uh it's just that setting a remote is
more convenient than email um
like doing all this via email seems very
error-prone and annoying
and it all feels very official right
because there's this command line
interface with all these things you have
to learn and you're supposed to name
your like github uh remote upstream
and or like origin and that makes it
seem really fancy but it's like not
actually that fancy again it's just
emailing you the dot git folder
essentially
um so let's talk about github and this
applies equally to any other
hosting service like bitbucket or gitlab
basically github is just any other
working copy um so at its core there's a
really nice ui
uh that's just a wrapper around the get
command line interface which is great
because the get command line interface
is like
the most complicated part of git
um it's really easy to get overwhelmed
by that command line interface and so
github makes it a lot friendlier for
people who are trying to like get
started using version control and
understand what's happening
uh of course there's some added
conveniences
so right git doesn't have this idea of
like a canonical or default branch and
github lets you set that so that if you
go to the repository by default it's
going to show you that default branch so
that's why if you go into
a repo at work maybe it'll show you like
main or master
and github has added these features over
time that let you
edit from within github and that lets
you treat it like a real working copy so
you can actually make commits within
github um that's because it is a real
working copy
uh github also gives better user uh
visibility at the user level so you can
see what are all of the repositories
that this person has contributed to
uh things like that and then there's
also like organization level like
concepts and permissioning adds more
security so there's lots of great using
reasons to use github it's very useful
but fundamentally it's another working
copy
uh so just a few final thoughts uh to
wrap up
so
again git
is a really complicated command line
interface and i think that is what
people think of as git
and so it feels very overwhelming and
scary but actually the tool itself is
really simple um it's just like
compressing and hashing everything and
just chucking it into one folder
um
it's like um deceptively simple
so what i want to encourage you to do is
when you run into an error or a conflict
and you like start to panic um don't do
what i did and just like delete your
entire repo just take a step back and
look at it from git's perspective
so take a second to think about like
what is in my docket folder right now
um what's in my working copy and is that
different than what is in the doc get
folder
and then if you're trying to pull and
you get some kind of um error when
you're trying to run a git polar and get
fetch what's in the remote how might
that be different from my dot get how's
that different from my working copy and
how is like the the differences between
these things like how could that be sort
of
creating um the error that i'm seeing
and i also want to make a pitch for
spending a couple hours being frustrated
trying to build git from scratch so
if you try to build your own version
control system it's going to give you a
lot of information about how it works
why it works what's hard about it
um
you know it doesn't need to be something
that you're going to use you can build
it in python you can do whatever
but it's a really interesting and useful
exercise
um so that's pretty much it i want to
leave you with a few resources and i'll
post these slides on my
website
uh so git is simpler than you think is
an article that i referenced really
heavily when i was writing this uh talk
um it really goes into the get internals
at a really understandable level and
it's it's pretty quick read
git internals is an online resource it's
really in the weeds but it's kind of
like a useful reference so i did some of
my like fact checking
uh using that and then i also have to
make a quick pitch for the recurs center
which is sort of like a writer's retreat
for programmers it's all virtual right
now but
um when i went it's like you go in
person into like a big room for a few
months and collaborate with people on
whatever you want and that's where i did
that original exercise to try to build
version control in python from scratch
um so
if you have the opportunity to go to the
record center or program like that it's
a great way to um really learn about
this stuff
um and that is it for me so with that
i'm happy to take any questions
thank you so much eli this is really
exciting stuff my mind is blown i for
sure for sure learned something and el
has a question we have about two minutes
left what is the difference between git
fetch and git pull
uh yeah great question so get fetch
um just does the like emailing into your
dot get folder
thing so it doesn't affect
it it doesn't do a merge into your
branch um it just like pulls those
objects into your dot get
um so i i believe that get pull is
actually just a wrapper around running
get fetch and then get
merge
or something along those lines
awesome hey thank you so much for your
talk and uh
thank you
thanks everyone